well as we look back at this past year
the push continues
right now to get as many nevadans
vaccinated as possible
bianca holman is live from a health
clinic where the most vulnerable are now
getting the services they need hi bianca
i'm here at lutheran social services of
nevada located here on boulder highway
and this is where homeless men and women
are getting
the health resources that they so
desperately need
matter of fact right here in this
parking lot there were several resources
everything that you can imagine the
nevada homeless alliance has items for
pets they've got bathing stations for
people they've got hiv
screenings clothes and shoes but most
importantly those who are eligible are
able to get the coleman 19 vaccine
physical assistance students from toro
university nevada were on hand
answering questions providing health
screenings and administering the shot
we've always been very committed to
going out and helping our community
so we've been doing events like this for
a long time so great for now that things
are opening up and people are more
immunized and our numbers are going down
so great that we can get back to
providing medical care but also
providing vaccines
i think vaccines are going to be the
real key to getting las vegas back on
its feet
now those 55 and older with underlying
conditions received the one dose
johnson and johnson vaccine and we're
told more clinics like this are planned
for the future
reporting from boulder and lamb bianca
holman 8 news now